i'm madison mills president trump just
announced that the fda
issued an emergency use authorization
for a treatment involving blood plasma
the fda says it stops the mortality rate
of coveted patients by 35
but is it really safe or effective to
answer these questions and go over the
breaking news we're joined by dr william
shaffner doctor thank you so much for
joining us this evening and
sunday night here in new york uh let's
just start by going over the news
what did president trump announce today
and what do we know about
convalescent plasma treatments let's
start with convalescent plasma
so that when people are infected
the body fights off the infection and we
recover
as a part of that process the body makes
proteins that circulate in the blood
those are called antibodies
those are the proteins that fight off
the virus
and so the notion is that could we
harvest
that plasma that's the yellow part the
liquid part
of the blood could we harvest that
and actually use it to treat people who
are sick
there's a long history of that goes back
a hundred years
so plasma has been used for the
treatment
of other infectious diseases most
recently
ebola so it's a nice idea we use plasma
for lots of things
of course it has some side effects but
we know about them
so we think we can do this in a very
managed way
and as a matter of fact over 70 000
people
already in the united states have been
treated
with this convalescent plasma
now question is not whether it's safe
we know how to do that it's pretty darn
safe
question is does it do any good
and so far we have accumulated
short small studies and one
fairly large study but it was not a
controlled study
unfortunately and so it's a whole lot of
individual observations analyzed
carefully and it looks as though it
might be working
in fact according to the statement that
was made in the news conference
it improves survival by 35
excuse me but does it really
the only way to really know that of
course
is if you do a controlled trial you
alternate patients
some get the plasma some get a placebo
and then we watch how the
illness progresses and we compare the
treatment
arm with the untreated arm a lot of
people will say why do you have to go
through all that rigmarole
well just cycle back
a short time hydroxychloroquine was also
given an emergency use
authorization by the fda
once the studies were in we discovered
although it looked good at the beginning
it really wasn't very good at all
there wasn't any documented clear
benefit
and the emergency use authorization had
to be withdrawn
so what we have now is early
data and i think the
the the commissioner of the fda
i don't want to misquote him uh said
that this was
uh of promising efficacy
and the data suggests that it would work
his comments much more conservative
than the president's enthusiasm and
that's where most of us
are our hearts would like this to work
our brains say ah we don't really have
the data yet
all that said the emergency use
authorization
will make it easier for patients across
the country and their doctors
to have access to this treatment should
they
wish to use it and doctor you mentioned
in your answer you
said something along the lines of we
know that this is safe um but
i think a lot of people are concerned
that it may not be um we heard
dr fauci uh pushing back against the
emergency use authorization last week
which is pretty recent so what would you
say to folks who are concerned
about a treatment like this as i said
we have used plasma treatment for any
number of
other illnesses not all infectious
diseases
we give plasma therapy all the time in
our medical center so there are adverse
events
we know how to manage them so from my
point of view
the safety issue is very small with this
treatment the big issue and i think the
reason dr fauci was cautious is
we don't really know that it will work
and we need more rigorous data to show
that it works
my notion is that we have kind of a
grade
c data to show that it will work
i would truly like grade a
and actually getting the grade a data is
going to be harder now
because with this emergency youth use
authorization lots of people
will be wanting it and it will be much
more difficult to recruit the patients
into the clinical trial that brings me
to another question how do we decide
who gets this potential treatment
um and is there enough supply for for
folks to have it around the world
well certainly not around the world but
we've already
managed to treat about uh 70 000 plus
patients in fact in the news conference
they said 100 000 which is even larger
than i
understood was the case but in any event
we were being urged this evening
if you've recovered from known covid
go in and donate your plasma and you can
do that
several times they take out the plastic
give you
your red blood cells back it's a pretty
standard procedure that's done in any
blood bank
so that the donations can also be pretty
quick
and very safe so that process
is all right question still comes back
how effective is it when do you give it
in the course of the illness for maximum
effect
if there is one and how many doses do
you have to give
those nuances are still not
known i wish from the beginning
the very first patient who got plasma
treatment would have been entered
into a clinical trial that's really the
best way to do it
because if that had happened by now we
would really know how good it is
doctor we're getting in some audience
questions while we're speaking we have
one from zach wright who's asking what
does the plasma do and you touched on
this in your first answer but can you
just
describe to our audience how this plasma
actually helps patients
um and whether it could potentially
prevent covin
sure so what the plasma does
let's go back and look at the infection
the virus
is acquired it attaches to the cells in
the back of our throat
begins to multiply and spread from cell
to cell
and then it can get into the bloodstream
and go to other
organs in the body what this plasma has
are the antibodies the proteins
that can actually catch the virus
envelope it and prevent it from
entering new cells so it
stops the progression of the disease
and so you can think of it really as a
kind of
direct antiviral treatment
and so by halting the progression of the
seat
of the disease that gives your body a
chance
to then recover how does it compare to
something else like dexamethasone for
example
in comparison to dexamethasone which is
an anti-inflammatory drug that just
dampens the hosts over response
this is a direct anti-viral
medication it attacks the actual
covet virus itself the whole cause
of the problem and so we think
probably early on in the disease when
you're just severe enough to be admitted
to the hospital
that's probably the very best time at
the moment
to get this plasma treatment
and of course this is developing as
we've talked about there are a lot of
questions surrounding this treatment but
do we know anything about
the potential long-term effects uh
and how long it lasts could patients get
coveted again later on i think
there are just a lot of developing
questions about long term
yeah remember we're writing the textbook
as we go along it will probably have
some effect for a period of at least
three to four to six weeks something on
that order of magnitude
because by that time the body has
metabolized
this plasma that's been infused
now whether you can get covet again
after plasmid therapy we don't know
and what about uh the mortality rate
impact can you
talk about that a little more and how uh
potentially life-saving this could be
for folks
now it i mean it is being touted
on the basis of these rather preliminary
data that have been carefully analyzed
but they're still rather preliminary
data it was said that mortality
can be reduced by 35
which is true is very large and very
impressive
i think most of us are a little bit
skeptical
because we don't really know what sort
of patients have been treated
and what stage of the infection they're
in you know we haven't seen
these data yet we would like to look at
them more carefully
and when you have just uh information
on a whole lot of people who have been
treated
and no comparison group you have to be
very cautious about drawing conclusions
hard and fast about how effective it is
is this something that you would
recommend to your patients
you've been using it here at vanderbilt
for some time
and two of my vanderbilt colleagues
are just starting a major multi-location
across the united states
trial to try to actually compare
plasma therapy with patients who don't
receive it
boy as of the announcement this evening
people are going to be very difficult to
recruit into that trial
and tell me a little more about that why
why do you think that is
you enter the trial in effect you flip a
coin
and you say you get the plasma and you
don't
so you have to allow chance to determine
whether you're getting plasma or not and
here
we have the political leadership of the
country standing behind
and advocating plasma treatment
and calling it a breakthrough
i wish that uh the political leadership
had not made this announcement
from my point of view this announcement
should have come from rockville maryland
where the fda is
and it should have been done by the
professionals not the politicians
when politicians make announcements as
has been true for most of kovid it takes
a political cast a political
coloration as you know wearing a mask
that simple and very effective
intervention
that's taken a very political coloration
i wish the politicians had stood back
from this
in your view are you am i hearing
correctly that you think if the
president had not announced this tonight
folks would potentially be more
willing to get involved in trials that
could give us more information about the
effectiveness of this treatment
certainly would have been different it
would have been a great emphasis
i think on the professional side saying
we still
don't know exactly how effective this is
which is very different than the message
that came from the national leadership
and
we would have said it's very important
to
be recruited to volunteer for these
clinical trials
to find out exactly how well if at all
this plasma treatment works which
patients ought to get it
and what the doses are we need that
information desperately
we need you to volunteer for these
trials that's the announcement i would
have liked
i i want to go back to that in a minute
but you mentioned the president's
announcement
um at his news conference when reporters
were asking
questions about the fda he walked out uh
so i'm wondering if you can talk about
the political relationship with the fda
um is is there any concern that folks
should have
about the approval process that this
treatment went through
well i'm afraid many of us who are
professionals are very concerned about
that
because it has been our impression
that the fda has had pressure put upon
it in the past
to which it has succumbed the
hydroxychloroquine
episode is a case in point and so we're
very concerned
indeed i think the washington post
reported
that pressure was put on the fda
in fact someone in the white house said
some heat
had to be applied this is exactly the
circumstance where we don't need
heat we need cool analytical
approaches pressure bluster
have no pre have no place in medicine
and making these kinds of decisions that
are so important
to the care of patients so i'm hearing
you say
that there was political pressure
applied to the fda here but
simultaneously that you're seeing
success
in your patients you would recommend it
to your patients so
what's the takeaway for our audience who
just wants to know
does this save lives
we don't know how much
how how effective this treatment is
i always say talk to your doctor if you
have an
interest in it see if it's available in
your local
circumstance and what is the approval
process like for
getting an emergency authorization
issued
is it a rigorous process take us into
that decision making
yeah as was said at the news conference
the process is not as elaborate or
rigorous
as the process is for recommendation
and licensure in other words the
standards
are lower and even so
it is my impression there was great
debate
internally about whether the information
was strong enough to come out with this
emergency use
authorization it was said that the
decision was
vetted by a group of independent
scientists within the fda
but they're not independent the
independent group
is outside the fda and i don't think
this went through
any external advisory committee
of experts that were not associated with
the fda
that's more usually the process
certainly before an item is licensed
and completely approved for use
is that alarming to you that it didn't
go through that external approval
process
it's perfect and it makes me
very concerned about what the process
might be uh when it comes to
the evaluation of vaccines uh i i am
concerned again
that the full body of data rigorously
examined
and vetted by an external group of
experts
will be will be shortcut and
i'm i'm clearly concerned about it
and just circling back should folks who
are potentially interested in
volunteering for these trials
be concerned about their safety
actually with plasma therapy as i said
i think the risks are well defined
because we're very familiar with the use
of plasma therapy so in that sense
it's not new the question is how
should it be used in this particular
circumstance
against covid so any volunteer will be
fully informed about any potential risk
and they're always free to withdraw
any time they choose
how does it compare uh to a blood
transfusion or something that folks
might be a little more
familiar with i'm wondering just what
the process is like
of going through this trial
well a blood transfusion of course
everything that's in the bloodstream
with a plasma transfusion you only get a
liquid part
all the red blood cells are taken off
they're actually given back to the donor
so the donor doesn't lose those you just
lose the
liquid part and the body makes up that
liquid part
in a very short order so
you actually get a substance the plasma
which is less risky than a blood
transfusion
and we're getting a lot of great
audience questions and one of them is
can this help in vaccine research and
where are we in that process
the two are kind of related
because we're both dealing with the
production of antibodies
but they don't directly influence each
other
the work on vaccines is moving ahead
there are now three major vaccines in
this country
that are entering those very serious
large
clinical trials that will let us know
how effective
and how safe the vaccines are and of
course there are vaccines
that are also being studied in china in
russia
and other parts of the world
simultaneously
so there's a lot of science going into
the development of vaccines and that's
moving ahead
very intensely and very
carefully dr schaffner you've given us
your sunday evening so we are going to
let you go here soon um but
before we do i just want to talk about
our the last time we spoke with you in
january
uh feels like eons ago at this point but
when we spoke you said the us was ready
to handle this pandemic that
they were ready for any cases that might
land here um
how do you feel about that now a lot has
changed
an enormous amount has changed we've all
learned
so much and i and everyone else
who thought we understood well we didn't
think we understood
we thought this new coronavirus this
covet virus
was similar to its cousins
sars and myrrhs also coronaviruses that
jumped species
but we discovered shortly after that
that actually
covet was very different those two
viruses
did not spread very readily this one
spreads like wildfire and that's made
all the difference so this
cousin behaved very differently than its
two
other viruses that to which it was
related
and that was the big surprise i think
to virtually all of us myself certainly
included
were there any big surprises for you
regarding the us's handling of the virus
well now you make me very sad because
yes
the response to the virus has been
disjointed
it has not had strong federal leadership
it has put the premier public health
agency of the world the cdc
off to the side it's been led mostly
by our political leadership rather than
our professional leadership
and we really have not had a coherent
comprehensive national plan
that has been clearly communicated
so i think the united states
i'm sorry gets an f when it comes to the
response
and i know i said i was about to let you
go but just given
what you just talked with us about
should folks trust
the president's advice on treatments
like this given
uh the federal response to the pandemic
so far
i always urge people to listen to the
public health authorities
they were not much in evidence today but
they are the ones in whom
i have the most confidence dr schaffner
thank you so much for making time with
us
this sunday evening for folks watching
thanks for joining please follow
bloomberg quick take on all social
platforms wherever you get your news
have a great night thank you